GINA CLINE: Just called in.
We're half a click
inside Chechnya.
Not too late to turn back.
US military operating on Russian
soil constitutes an act of war.
We've been ordered to trade
Nasry for the president's guy.
Those are our orders.
We will complete them.
Understood?
Clear.
Nothing better to do.
You're the boss.
Delta 3?
I'm here, aren't I?
Yes, you are.
[gunfire]
Time.
You beat your time
by a full second.
I'm really happy for you.
Yeah, well, we still
have half a second to go,
but the tide is turning.
- What?
Alex?
We're here, beautiful
downtown Kishnet.
[speaking russian]
He said welcome.
They've been expecting us.
Anzor, welcome to Kishnet.
Joe, you got any more
men of fighting age here?
We're all fighting age here.
Prince's men came at night.
Told me we agreed
to host exchange.
They gave us money.
We don't.
They gave us trouble.
How many of them?
Two.
Hmm.
It's enough when
you are the prince.
Well, I mean no
disrespect, Anzor,
but I don't think I'd
be taking that deal.
Hmm.
[sighs] When this is
over, you will leave,
and we'll still be here.
Can Chloe come
over for dinner?
That girl you just met?
I know you're scared, Mom.
But I made a new friend.
She's really nice.
OK.
You must be Chloe.
Nice to meet you, Mrs. Ortiz.
Oh, please, call me Jackie.
And act normal.
No more guns.
When you see the
prince, you're going
to tell him about
a mid-level career
used by the Uma movement.
He handles small-time
errands for one
of the prince's lieutenants.
He's a CIA asset.
Convince him you're
still valuable.
You'd sacrifice
your own asset?
When necessary.
MAN (ON RADIO): Delta 1,
we might have something.
Six armed unknowns
approaching the village.
Delta 1, this is Delta 6.
Two pickups just pulled up.
It's at least six
men with small arms.
Yeah, a local warlord.
But they'll know who I am.
Let me see what they want.
[speaking russian]
[gunfire]
Usha, we got our answer.
It's an ambush.
Delta, I got hostiles
coming from the south.
[gunfire]
Delta 1, this is Delta 6.
We are rolling in from the east.
[gunfire]
We can't hold them back.
I'm letting Nasry go.
We let Nasry go,
and we game it out.
He makes his way
back to the prince,
and we buy Andrew
Hall more time.
It goes one of two ways.
The prince kills Nasry.
You get what you want.
That's option one.
What's option two?
Tables get turned.
Nasry kills the prince.
And I get what I want.
But if we bring Nasry
back, neither happens.
And Hall dies.
Bear, we put two bullets in
the back of Nasry's skull right
now, and we end this.
OK?
I hear what you're saying.
An eye for an eye, brother.
We're not going to do that.
I know you think you're right.
But you're wrong.
Well, right or wrong,
this is my choice to make.
Pretend you
escaped the attack.
The prince's men
own these mountains.
OK, here's your alternative.
I take you back.
The prince kills Hall.
And you're worthless.
The agency sends your
away, account closed.
You disappear,
this time for good.
Your family, the treatment
for your father stops.
You can forget about him.
And yeah, you may survive
the torture to live
out your life in a hole.
But what kind of life is that?
I'm giving you an opportunity.
How is this an opportunity?
You give me the prince, and
I'll give you his kingdom.
You don't have the
power to do that.
Michael, it's
what the CIA does.
You need to see a
specialist about your head.
Well, if I see one
of our Navy docs,
it'll end up on
my medical record.
I can't afford
that, not if I want
to make it back on the team.
Well, my friend Bridges said.
He's a neurologist.
He's not in the military.
He'd keep it private.
Mr. Calder, you have
a serious brain injury.
I was shot in the hand.
Your hand isn't the problem.
The level of brain bruising
and bleeding you suffered
is excessive.
My guess is this wasn't
your first concussion.
We're done here.
The next one could be fatal.
Maybe not immediately.
You could feel the
effects the next day,
or the next week, or next year.
But you will feel the effects.
There's something
I need to tell you.
No matter what happens to
you, no matter where you go,
I will kill you.
You will pay for what you did.
You memorize the
number I gave you?
Tell them you used
this to escape.
It's unloaded.
You have two rounds.
You got 10 seconds to get
the [muted] out of here
before I shoot you.
[music playing]